hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast so
Monday August 7th lucky 7 2017 what's
going on dude he yell he said 7:00
I thought 7:00 and then he yelled lucky
7 dude I'm going to play that [ __ ]
number dude I'm going down to Christie's
and I'm getting me a [ __ ] set for
life getting seven of them why can't I
[ __ ] hear myself I'm screaming loud
enough running you know people when
you're not talented what you have to do
is yell you don't believe that watch my
[ __ ] last [ __ ] whatever I mean I
don't know how many special I've done
you know when you talk in the amount of
[ __ ] I do why can't I hear myself the
way I want to hear myself why can't I
hear me the way I used to am I going
deaf so what's going on how's that is
that too much
hello hello test one two two two two two
two two two two two the [ __ ] is what
this thing do I have an eye on some sort
of [ __ ] parental mode you know
hearing loss is one of the number one
causes of hearing loss in 2017 because
these ear buds that are all the rage
with the children I actually had time
today to go over and go play drums today
and I put on a [ __ ] a DD Clinic Jesus
Christ
I like practice 9000 things got better
at nothing that's how I practice a let's
do double bass for two minutes a let's
work on singles and doubles triplets
right just kept going and going but you
know what I didn't sound that bad I had
a good time I [ __ ] love that kit
though I had the small setup a lot of
you guys gave me [ __ ] cuz I had [ __ ]
three floor toms Legos what you doing
before you [ __ ] - you know your
[ __ ] toupee I don't own a toupee
alright you can't own a toupee
it just it you know what I mean I though
I bet they make them really good right
now but I just would just be like
wearing this [ __ ] hat you could never
take off you know you wake up in the
morning
and you got you little roller you know
with the glue you know and you just
[ __ ] going over your scalp you know
you're doing that your wife comes
walking in I mean Jesus Christ I mean
she's gonna be banging another guy
within three days if your [ __ ] woman
walks in while you're gluing hair to the
top of your head all right and she
doesn't leave you that woman is a saint
you know what I mean
I love the guys who have like the
[ __ ] the toupee and then they can't
even get like the stud like the decides
to match it you know what I mean it's
like do you [ __ ] colorblind do you
really think that that that's blending
into what you got on the sides you know
it's funny too is when you go down the
toupee Road they don't know as far as I
know they don't make any white ones like
if you're an older guy so then you got
to dye the [ __ ] you got on the side
right so then it just makes people look
at your head like you just like this
guy's like 60 how does he have jet lag
good lord look at that [ __ ] thing Jay
you know I don't like about toupees
actually hair plugs now is there to good
now used to being used to be able to
tell you can really [ __ ] somebody up in
conversation y'all need to do I don't
give a [ __ ] how smart they were led to
do is just kind of look up at and then
look back at them and then they were
just [ __ ] for the rest of the
conversation and those days are gone now
because they got too goddamn good at it
so anyways I was playing you know
playing all the drums [ __ ] at this point
because my drum teacher is out on the
road I haven't been taking any lessons
you know drum teacher Davey lets out
with the night game opening for Dave no
not that one said Dave Matthews no John
Mayer opening but John Mayer with Steve
Jordan on drums Jesus Christ you get to
seed a village and then you get to see
Steve Jordan how about that hey there's
a [ __ ] evening for you you know
that'd be enough to get goddamn
millennials
yes oh I haven't been taking lessons but
uh so I just it's actually kind of been
a good thing because I can go back to
all this [ __ ] that I never [ __ ] got
down that he showed me while developing
new bad habits
but I know I'm kidding anyways I'm
having a great time so people give me
[ __ ] cuz I got the three floor toms but
this is why I did it this was the method
to my madness all right I got 12 inch
rack then I got a 14 16 18 floor Tom so
then a 22 kick right so I hate having to
rat Tom's but I ended up ordering
another one so I got a 12 I got 13
comments so now I can go bigger small
people bigger small I can even go 12 14
16 or 13 16 18 depending on whatever the
[ __ ] whatever song I'm going to go
butcher on the goddamn comedy gin
alright
why can't I just have a hobby without
people criticizing it like you can't
people just say hey nice drum kit the
dad dude what do you got two three
[ __ ] four so four I got to say in
Jesus I don't know I'm trying to get out
of the [ __ ] the bottom of death spin
I went on for [ __ ] 30 years I'm just
trying a different setup that's all I
was doing get more goddamn [ __ ] for that
that in saying nucular instead of
nuclear you know I love the word police
you know what I mean it's just like when
you're going to get in life with that
you know it's not new killer its nuclear
I've always said nuclear I've always
said it it sounds right to me
rolls off the tongue a little bit easier
than nuclear it's a nuclear weapon not
nuclear laughing my ass off let me ask
you this where are you laughing your ass
off where exactly are you in your
[ __ ] life because it's dumb as I am
I'm doing all right
you know is there is there a [ __ ] job
that you can do when you dot all your
i's cross all your T's and correct
spelling are you going to be like I
guess a teacher is that what it is do I
have a bunch of teachers following me on
Twitter I don't know why they wouldn't
you know good lord
these [ __ ] people that always liked
him there's so much [ __ ] I used to say
Paulo instead of pillow if they'll pal
is off the [ __ ] - every night I've
you know just [ __ ] you just say in a
different way because that mean you
don't know what the [ __ ] you put your
head on at night where does that get you
can you make a living doing crossword
puzzles those are those kind of they
could at soduku is pseudo coo over the
[ __ ] you say that pseudo cool dude oh
boy alright they're dead good at that
[ __ ] dude she's really smart she can do
the New York Times she can do the New
York Times crossword puzzle great
Fantana where does that get you what
does that get you in life I mean I don't
know I mean - tell me tell me how that's
holding me back that's what I want to
know I know I'm kind of harping on this
but who's like the 900th word you guys
have [ __ ] corrected me on it I don't
give a [ __ ] I like new killer sounds
like it's more [ __ ] like the missiles
spinning a little bit more nuclear like
nuclear could keep it clear here it
comes
nuclear silo it's little shoulder roll
in there new killer I like I'm keeping
it [ __ ] off you know do you guys like
right [ __ ] jay-z every time he says
ho when you're like actually it's or
laughing my ass off I bet you don't
right because you're liberals you know
but you've you a [ __ ] white male
[ __ ] up and what do you do you hold my
[ __ ] alabaster feet to the fire don't
you I've had a little bit I've had
enough of it
all right I've had enough of people
trying to make me not set like I'm
ashamed of how stupid I am I'm not okay
I saw the carrot man and I walked
towards it I knew what I was good at I
knew being a loudmouth [ __ ] [ __ ] was
what I was good at and I just did that
okay I'm not going to ever be in a
classroom teaching people how to spell
or pronounce [ __ ] okay
so let it go the ship has
there's no hope for me all right but you
know what the drill is the real reason
people they're not doing it for me
they're doing it for them to show how
smart they are
oh it's not portal it's turtle laughing
my ass off I know how to say that
[ __ ] amphibians name
oh but actually it's not an affair yes
it's not an afib Ian and Infineon has
you do any shutoff what you know just
what those people are they practicing to
be on a game show is that what it is
that's like this smart way a person
plays the lottery I guess right the
lottery you just could be a dope like me
going so do you see that nuclear weapon
and then you go and let me get a [ __ ]
set for life right that's how I try to
make it okay the smartypants who can do
the [ __ ] who can actually do the New
York Times crossword puzzle is now you
know try to get on like wheel of fortune
because you know that's like the [ __ ]
dumbest crossword you can do whatever
the [ __ ] it is that a crossword no it
isn't right it's like guess the letters
it looks like a crossword but it is but
I just love that you can be smart enough
to do the New York Times crossword
puzzle and then still you got to get on
there right and you got to spin a wheel
and spin that wheel there's no
intelligence you just spin it and you
can be the smartest person on the world
and you're going to roll lose a turn or
bankrupt and it's [ __ ] over
I like watching jeopardy when you know
there's somebody just you just can't
defeat this guy and all these other
smarty pants get on there and their
whole life they were the [ __ ]
smartest one you know you know those
people that don't like drink and they
like they played board games like let's
play Trivial Pursuit you know what I
mean let's let's play whatever those
[ __ ] games I got to tell you some of
the saddest moments in my adult life is
I've gone to parties and all of a sudden
they break out board games and you ever
see like when somebody's on hidden vid
yo and they start looking around like
what the [ __ ] and the crowd starts
laughing like that's the look on my face
like yeah then they're not going to do
this they're not doing this other
because everybody have to play I don't
want to do this I don't want to [ __ ]
with you one of my five years old you
know we trapped in a [ __ ] cabin and
then there's no television no this is
creed you can connect with I'll play
some cards you know I like how cards is
like I would love a cards it's just like
there's a sleazy Veck vibe to cards that
I've always enjoyed even though I don't
play a lot of cards but you know even
like those [ __ ] old ladies seen some
old lady with her bony fingers [ __ ]
shuffling not even looking talking some
[ __ ] she's got her favorite little
candies right to the right you know and
a dish
you know I saw an old-school old lady
today I was in I went out at the grocery
store buying some [ __ ] food right and
this lady comes around the corner she
had on like this
turquoise blazer with like some sort of
brooch I forget what she had underneath
it she had white slacks on white shoes
and a white purse just old school
dressed to the [ __ ] night she looked
great
total [ __ ] class act made me miss my
grandmother my grandmother was a sharp
dresser they would make those people
they know how to [ __ ] dress you know
what I mean and then they'd buy a pair
of shoes and goddamnit they don't care
not like us today you know well every
black person I knew they always took
care of their [ __ ] sneakers you know
what I mean keep the [ __ ] things
looking brand new you know taking out a
goddamn you know the nail brush
scrubbing the sides right there was
another white privilege moment right now
you just dab dirty sneakers and that was
okay what man I went outside they got
dirty we only keep watching they just
he's always going to be dirt out here
man
number one patrice used to give me [ __ ]
for my sneakers being dirty is just like
ah be lay in a [ __ ] beauty pageant
he's like bill if you were black and you
walked out like I'm not black this is
totally socially acceptable for me
I get it you have new sneakers on
congratulations
anyways I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about I'm doing this this Sunday
night because as always I have a million
things to do during this time of year as
we're writing season 3 3 3 a family
family family we're going to be
recording episode 3 and writing episode
4 this week big [ __ ] going we're almost
at the clubhouse turn in now I text you
the coming down the backstretch you know
I think we'll have 5 written and
recorded by the end of this this month I
know you guys are thinking so what does
that mean it comes out in December oh no
no there's like 40 different other
things you have to do to it over the
course of the next I don't know how many
months before it finally [ __ ] comes
out I have no idea we would joke on one
time I think by the time we do the sixth
season I'll be in my late sixties but I
have to tell you I really [ __ ] like
it I really like doing it and I really
enjoy being in the writers room you know
some days it sucks when like the [ __ ]
just isn't working and my brain isn't
working and I'm fried some of those days
suck but generally but then you know
everybody else is saying funny [ __ ] so
that makes you get going you know but I
actually really enjoy writing dialogue
who would have thought you know in a way
I can you know some guy who says nuclear
can actually write a [ __ ] episode of
television you know just think about
that okay think about think about that
and then stop complaining about who's
president right now okay if you can say
nuclear and then you can [ __ ] I mean
like George Bush you say nucular the
amount of people that [ __ ] laughed at
him and I want to be like hey are you
bilingual can you also speak Spanish huh
did you go to Yale the guy went to
[ __ ] Yale all right I don't give a
[ __ ] of his dad got a minute what he's a
legacy he still went there you still got
that education still got to be a member
of the Skull and Bones I think that's
why you had that last
we didn't belong there anyway guys we
just got pushed down that [ __ ] road
you know we think he really wanted to do
I think like what you do after your prep
your president really lets people know
how much you love the job you know what
I mean and like he just [ __ ] disabil
Clinton he still you know Bill Clinton
was all about the horse you know so he
still he's still out there giving
speeches I nice [ __ ] pets right he's
still out there you know Jimmy card is
building [ __ ] homes you know and then
he got [ __ ] uh George Bush he's just
he's [ __ ] hanging out like a
trust-fund kid he just sit around Peyton
you ever see that documentary rich kids
like one of the saddest [ __ ] things
I've ever seen in my life was like these
people they were born into such wealth
like one of them was they were part of
that Johnson & Johnson family which I
think a lot of people don't know what
that is but like when I was growing up
everything was made by Johnson & Johnson
I'm sure they got bought out whatever
but when I guess when they bought that
out Johnson & Johnson they built it in
that their kids would always just be
taken care of and would have I don't
know position the company they were just
getting money it's this [ __ ] beast
that Johnson & Johnson built just it the
inertia of that [ __ ] thing just
tearing through the capitalist economy
right was just so big that they just if
they just like if they get the skin
remember [ __ ] casino the skin but the
kids still get the skin and the [ __ ]
skim alone they get a little [ __ ]
duffle bag of cash that they don't ever
have to work in their life right and I
would think that that'd be true that
would be the [ __ ] greatest thing ever
that would be the greatest thing ever
and it kind of turned out that it wasn't
I think it would be the greatest thing
ever if you actually live the other way
first but even then I think I think
it'll get boring after a while do you
think he could do it
I think if you just had enough money
where you never had to work again my
thought would be well the next big thing
in my life is I'm going to die that's
the the next eventful thing I have no
deadlines I have no worries oh man I
would get like psycho obsessed with [ __ ]
you know like I do already but I've been
like my real life takes over I can play
dumb
I think I'm [ __ ] Florez an asylum
play all [ __ ] time and then like my
real life to a you got to go into the
writers room and then it eases it off
like if I just [ __ ] was sitting there
like when I was talking to you guys
about that building in Manhattan the one
that looks like a giant cigarette
something Park Avenue and I was like
what the [ __ ] is that thing that thing's
bigger than the Freedom Tower and I went
back and I looked at those pictures that
they have from the penthouse in that
building and that bathtub you know that
bathtub everybody has now it's it's
shaped like like the [ __ ] Chicago
Bears Stadium you know that one that
freestanding one it's not on legs like
it's it's big the ladies love it
evidently right and it's right up on the
[ __ ] window and you can just look out
all the way south of Manhattan past the
Statue of Liberty to see the [ __ ] you
know whenever the Germans come to attack
us again sig you know this person in the
[ __ ] tub is going to see it first
right the Japanese I should say I just
figured that side of the country you
know the Germans would be coming right
with their nuclear weapons actually why
would you bring it over here you just
[ __ ] shoot it off with you anyway so
I was just looking at it I was just
trying to imagine sitting in that tub
taking a bath that that would be one of
the saddest experiences you could
possibly have it looks so [ __ ] lonely
first one I saw was like holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] unbelievable that looks
like I feel like I'm in a helicopter but
you're like in a [ __ ] building but
just being that high up you can't even
hear the city anymore
just how quiet it would be you know you
littered you're getting to that love
that thing that astronauts see you like
the astronauts they would go out and
they would orbit the Earth and they
would just look down at it and they will
above all the [ __ ] all the politics
all the religion all the [ __ ] war all
the disease all the suffering and they
look down and they were able to see how
beautiful it was the paradise that we
actually live in we just sit here with
all his petty [ __ ] and like these guys
would come back and they couldn't talk
to anybody about it couldn't give
anybody else that perspective unless
they talk to a fellow astronaut so then
they would just be you know pulling up
to a stoplight and they would see
something they would just randomly start
crying I think that would happen if I
took a bath that high above [ __ ]
Manhattan and you're just looking out
all good smell why can't like isn't why
don't we ever do the right you'd be
philosophically just saying why don't we
do the right thing why are we always
like you can't that's that's that's
that's too scary that's why all pilots
are a little [ __ ] weird there's
something weird about going up there and
just looking down at all of it you know
like a higher being and you also get to
see what the [ __ ] would go into the
planet it's a really [ __ ] it's a
weird thing and then you combine that
with the fact that you're taking a bath
where the most relaxing thing ever just
looking down at this [ __ ] terror I
don't know I also kind of wonder like
with global warming like what's going to
happen you know
I'm sorry climate change I didn't mean
to shock you by saying global warming I
hope I didn't ruin your day with those
two [ __ ] words let me say climate
change you can [ __ ] relax a little
bit still understand why they say that
climate change it's like what the
Halliburton changed its [ __ ] name
right well they change it to peaches and
cream I can't [ __ ] remember anyways I
was just thinking that like the more
like severe the weather's going to get
like what will that mean you know like
we can expect some crazy storms we've
never [ __ ] seen before I wonder if
they took that into consideration when
they built that goddamn thing that all
of a sudden you know we're going to
start getting like like steroid era Mark
McGwire era [ __ ] you know hurricanes
you know and this is going to be a
category 19 and you're up there taking a
[ __ ] bath watching this [ __ ] rolling
it you're going to go right out that
[ __ ] window in that tub all the way
down to the [ __ ] pavement but what a
way to go that Courson thing it'd be
like the cartoons we try to get the bath
water back into the [ __ ] tub it would
be a hell of a death I honestly think if
there is a God you know he would [ __ ]
take extra time he would take extra time
with you just being like like just
watching the game film of your death
going I mean it'd just be like you know
I've seen people die since the beginning
man I this this this is this is one that
this is definitely I've never seen this
one before
I never seen somebody in a bathtub at
1,350 feet I don't know I don't know why
I'm obsessed with that [ __ ] building
it's just I don't know there was just
something about it and the fact that
they can't sell the one underneath it
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever because who
the [ __ ] going to pay 85 million
dollars and still have somebody living
above them go you [ __ ] out there but
what am I paid for you anyways how about
those Red Sox huh how about those Red
Sox but you know something anyone safety
they're undefeated they went five in a
row undefeated this month alright and I
went on the I went on the old Internet
there right and I see I looked up the
standings the baseball standings yet
that that that would have been attended
a baseball one right
this weekend baseball dududududududududu
deliberate date a little early today to
death if you saw the highlights and
actually heard an orchestra playing what
I just played it tried to sing
he'd be tremendous so the Houston Astros
evidently are the other beasts of the
American League I was all excited that
we swept the White Sox I just realized
that they're 41 and 68 I guess that's
not such a big deal well we did what we
were supposed to do we kicked the [ __ ]
out of a man
we won six in a row gone eight and two
the last 10 picked up three games on
them [ __ ] Yankees you see [ __ ]
Aaron Judge 35th home run today had the
same trajectory as a base hit except for
one out of the park telling you it's
like [ __ ] Paul Bunyan coming to the
goddamn plate loving the Indians in
first place that'd be great to see them
win one let's test my knowledge all
right Red Sox last World Series 2013
Yankees 2009 Tampa Bay never said AB
shut the [ __ ] up
Baltimore Orioles 1983 Toronto Blue Jays
they went back-to-back 92 93 Cleveland
Indians 1948 Kansas City Royals 2015
last year was a Cubs right Minnesota
Twins 1991 Detroit 1984 Chicago White
Sox 2005 Houston Astros never Sam
Shepard [ __ ] Seattle Mariners never sit
and shut the [ __ ] so childish Los
Angeles Angels 2002 Texas Rangers you
know it never sands [ __ ] up
Oakland 89 Washington center's never sit
down shut the [ __ ] up Miami Marlins was
it 2003 Lana Braves is 95
New York Mets every Red Sox fan knows
that's 1986 Philadelphia Phillies 2008
Cubs 2016 Milwaukee Brewers never sit
down shut the [ __ ] up st. Louis
Cardinals oh [ __ ] I don't know this one
they always win the [ __ ] thing was it
2006 or they wanted this decade
Pittsburgh Pirates I don't know 71 the
Reds was 1990 the Dodgers was 88
Colorado Rockies never Arizona
Diamondbacks 2001 the one time I ever
rooted for the Yankees because it was
right after 9/11 I was like Iowa gets a
[ __ ] root for San Diego Padres never San
Francisco Giants I want to say they
wanted 2010 2012 and 2014
is that right 15 was the Royal 16 was
the Cubs yeah I'd say 2040 that's not
bad for somebody doesn't [ __ ] watch
baseball was that boring to you I'm
sorry let me let me do you know if that
was boring enough let me get to one of
the most exciting parts of this podcast
listening to me read out loud
alright here we go we got one two three
four one two three four one two three
four talking something about that the
other day when somebody had a doorbell
like that when I had a paper route when
I was a kid I thought that meant they
were rich they didn't just go Bing bong
a [ __ ] dentist real one if they
actually had the one went ding dong ding
dong ding dong ding dong you know what's
so weird is good answer the door before
it ended then the [ __ ] looking at you
all right oh look who's here but oppo
poke me on Dee's biondi's taking a bath
at 2,000 feet doo doo doo me undies me
undies Oh get the hooker I'm in this key
cuz I got 95 million bucks
I'm [ __ ] lonely I'm banging hookers
and I give them a pair of hooker of me
undies and their [ __ ] are velvety
soft sorry alright you want to look good
in your underwear what oh yeah and be
comfortable right but that perfect
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
style or
Comfort checkout me undies August is
national underwear month what did they
have to pay to get that I mean this is
national get a [ __ ] job money they
always have something this is
internationally national [ __ ]
blueberry pancake day I'm so [ __ ]
sick of saying I have to look that up
I'm just in a place in my house where I
can't get internet you know by the way
who [ __ ] the Dodgers would playing as
well as I did you know because they
think if you don't have spectrum you
can't [ __ ] watch your mother August
is national underwear month and to
celebrate the undies is jerkin out the
undies is making it easier than ever to
try the world's most comfortable
underwear by giving you a risk free
guarantee all national underwear a month
long if you don't love your me undies
they're free I love that keep a man we
don't want to back me undies gets it do
I return them and they just go gross and
they hang up on you keep up the undies
are made from lensing micro mode al
modal a sustainably sourced naturally
soft fabric that's proven to be three
times softer than cotton how did they do
that
no no they tickle somebody's ball bag
with each one you know well he laughed a
little more with Mike three times as
much micro Modell is an all-natural
breathable eco-friendly fabric extruded
from Austrian beech trees that actually
inhibits odor you know here we'd be into
just too [ __ ] smart times sometimes
what a [ __ ] figured out to do that
eco-friendly fabric okay that means it's
biodegradable extruded from Austrian
beech trees that actually inhibits odor
so you'll see you had like 10 subjects
with smelly balls and like you [ __ ]
smell their balls J Christ and then you
put that on we like in art it's not as
bad no stinky undies just soft and cool
and cozy male host read this line and
for the fellas input of fellas me undies
diamond seamed pouch cradles your jewels
it gives you stuff the support it needs
without feeling too tight female hosts
rebus
and further ladies me undies features
soft black seams that minimizes slippage
gross without sacrificing style you
[ __ ] lips are coming out there and
they're super comfy and every cut bikini
song boy short or cheeky brief what the
[ __ ] is that
what's a cheeky brief is that a [ __ ]
some sort of English clamp it's simple
if you don't love your me undies they're
free
CTA whatever that means now until August
31st get 20% off your first pair Plus
free shipping at me undies dot-com / /
that's me undies com / bro hey my undies
dot-com / / nuclear nuclear nucular I
just like that better ProFlowers profile
with [ __ ]
hey there's no reason to get anybody
flowers this month that's why you do it
you know hey fellas you want to shut her
up you're sick of saying there's no
spice in the relationship get a bouquet
of or is it bouquet of roses right I
don't like roses I always get the
[ __ ] yellow ones tulips tulips are
great they brighten up the [ __ ] room
they actually smell nice you know what I
mean I love the tulips you get them the
nice yellow ones right it reminds them
of the [ __ ] JLo diamond right a
Kobe's wife's butt diamond she got
that's what they remember you know what
I mean alright I don't talk - I almost
[ __ ] went too far on that one I was
going to talk about what you then put
the flowers in what you use as a face
and I'm not going to do that because I'm
going to be a little more classy alright
throw flowers talk about the last time
you spontaneously surprise someone with
something completely unexpected and how
it felt
I you know I try I try to [ __ ]
surprise my wife I can't she's too
perceptive she figures everything out
it's [ __ ] unbelievable I can't even
tell the story it's too [ __ ]
embarrassing I came to tell you but like
you I had my [ __ ] way I'd move
something around and it was just
something sitting on the windowsill in a
room full
five thousand knickknacks and it was
literally there for twenty minutes and
she came while she goes what is the blob
of blood they weren't on the [ __ ]
wind ourselves and I just went like I
bet you don't [ __ ] you [ __ ] you for
being so goddamn perceptive all the time
you have another [ __ ] guy in the
house it took me three days before I
realized he wasn't a plumber
alright ProFlowers wants to help you
surprise someone for no reason all the
while also surprising you with a special
deal for my listeners get 20% off any
[ __ ] goddamn computer so on 20% off
any unique summer rose bouquets rose
bouquets bouquets bouquets or any other
bouquet bouquet bouquet for $29 and one
I I've said it too many times I can't
hear the word anymore they're colorful
rainbow roses are always a hit if you
aren't sure what to send someone
ProFlowers bouquets
that's I said are guaranteed to stay
fresh for at least seven days or your
money back and your control and you
control the delivery date ProFlowers
gives you more bloom for the buck big
beautiful flowers with stems for your
money with more stems for your money to
get 20% off your summer roses or any
other bouquet of twenty nine dollars or
more go to proflowers.com and use my
promo code buret check out that's
proflowers.com and code burr don't wait
to make somebody's day you know when I
was a kid you just make them a mixtape
let your boom box with the [ __ ]
side-by-side tapes you know that's what
you do that's what you do all right Alex
Alex you're unique you don't walk like
anyone else talk like anyone else her
trip or sleep like anyone else so why is
your mattress one is your mattress one's
not at all because a truly customized
mattress will cost you five to ten
thousand [ __ ] dollars until now go to
helix sleep calm answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms they
developed with the help of the world's
leading origami eggs of biomechanic
experts the result the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on and a
robot being built in your exact imaging
helis customers report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality and for couples
they customize each side of the mattress
who's kidding who the love is slowly die
why not [ __ ] you know begin your
divorce by getting two different kinds
of mattresses in one begin your separate
lives with a your own customized side of
your mattress your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100% free and then after a while you
get that little divider you know up in
first class you guys ever get bumped up
various [ __ ] thing that'll ever
happen you grip you know what short of
Jesus coming back and you find out that
you did enough [ __ ] good deeds that
he gets saved or whatever your religion
is Mahmud comes back and does something
[ __ ] Abraham Buddha Elrond hobbit
whoever whoever you're waiting for
whoever you waiting for comes back okay
the only thing that's the only thing
better than if that shit's true right
the only thing better is [ __ ] you
know that little you get bumped up to
first class you know that little [ __ ]
divider you know and you fly
cross-country next to summary for six
hours you don't say one [ __ ] word to
each other all right if you want to
experience that at home you get a
customized mattress either side that's
the same thing and turn your loved one
into a complete stranger your mattress
arrives at your door in about a week and
shipping is free that's why everyone
from GQ magazine to Forbes are all
talking about hellix sleep you have 100
nights to try it out if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free and give
you a 100% refund no questions asked
only helix sleep calm slash bird get $50
off your order
that's hellix sleep talk calm / / helix
sleep calm / / and lastly but not
leastly
stamps calm the headliner they always go
on last no one can follow this read it's
nice it's quick it's a sink
I usually don't stumble over it okay I'm
like the post-office stamps calm never
closes whew shots fired unlike those
[ __ ] down the street we keep going
this is the 24 Hours of LeMans a [ __ ]
shipping print postage for lettuce or
packages at your convenience 24/7
keywords slash descriptors convenient
easy reliable and flexible that's how
I'm going to sell it guys I'm going to
use one of those adjectives each each
sentence stamped opcom brings all the
services of the US Post Office right to
your fingertips Jesus that's convenient
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer wow
that's easy
stamps.com makes it easy [ __ ] I just
said that they'll send you a digital
scale that automatically calculates
exact postage wow that's reliable stamps
calm will even help you decide the best
class of mail on your needs Jesus that's
flexible I use stamps calm anytime I'm
[ __ ] selling posters I'm going to war
myself out I used to M so calm and I'm a
[ __ ] I can figure it out so can you
right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the page
and type in Burke that stamps commenter
burr stamps calm never go to the post
office again alright we're done right we
get through it all beautiful beautiful
beautiful 20 minutes to go 20 minutes to
go I talk about everything I wanted to
talk about
did I mention Paul virzi has a stand-up
special that all things comedy network
is going to be producing our first
stand-up special and the buzz on the
road is vers he's out there killing it
like I knew he was gonna alright
August 13th at the Tarrytown theater in
beautiful Tarrytown New York picturesque
Tom Hanks [ __ ] Sleepless in Seattle
looking [ __ ] place right me and I oh
god damn is [ __ ] computer
[ __ ] screen keeps shutting up me and
Pete Davidson me get this back with me
there we go all right me and Pete
Davidson will be will be sort of the
masters of ceremony we were warming up
going out on stage together giving each
other [ __ ] trying out new jokes [ __ ]
around I'm going to try to come out
there in between shows I don't want to
slow down the taping but I would
definitely get out there sign whatever
you got take some pictures or whatever
I'll try to move it along or whatever
you know whatever I could do is [ __ ]
interact we have a few seats left I want
to sell this thing out it's really
important night for Paul and the all
things comedy Network so I'd appreciate
it if he got the time you want to listen
to you know some comedy come on down
August 13th all right clown ahead and
I'll be at the Count Basie Theatre this
weekend out in Jersey out New Jersey Red
Bank New Jersey which is really
beautiful I might go to Asbury Park
during the day I have no idea what I'm
going to do because I usually stay in
the city I think I'm going to [ __ ]
stay somewhere out in Jersey you know
maybe I'll call [ __ ] what's-his-face
of any brand Vinny brand has a boat I'm
terrified of the ocean gonna go out in
the [ __ ] ocean with a goddamn club
owner why not
all right okay here we go the probably
with North Korea
dear Ronald McDonald balls North Korea
is a serious threat to East Asia and now
too good a portion of the world I
understand that so what so will we so a
week you know if you're going to play
this game you know what I mean like
everybody that said the Patriots cheated
if you're going to play that game then
you got to see the cheating that you are
doing correct
my nuts here am I crazy yes the missile
test the other day was a ballistic
missile but they can put a nuclear
weapon on it as well okay so can we we
already we already have ours ready to go
the latest test puts most of the US all
of Europe and a good portion of Africa
within range of their weapons
yes and all of those places are in range
of our weapons and Russia's weapons so
you know I mean look I'm not saying it's
great that this guy has this [ __ ]
thing but just imagine if he had what we
had what the [ __ ] would we be doing
wouldn't we be doing the same [ __ ]
thing well we got to get some stuff he's
making that [ __ ] because we got our [ __ ]
right it's like when the Yankee started
spending 200 million [ __ ] dollars the
Red Sox had to spend 190 that's what
happens that's what happens and if they
are actually able to successfully launch
from a submarine as they are attempting
to do this this not only increases the
range but can potentially dramatically
increase the amount of time we have to
respond if they were to launch a missile
well what would happen sir listen
everybody knows there's no end game to
this [ __ ] okay it's good it's going to
be over we would have time to respond
don't you remember what the [ __ ] was at
wargames I can't believe how seriously
people are [ __ ] taking this [ __ ] like
I don't think this guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind in North Korea all right
I'm just so [ __ ] sick of having to
turn on the TV and have somebody has to
try it it's like news now is just scare
the [ __ ] out of somebody and offer no
[ __ ] solutions and then normal people
just sit there screaming at each other
to the point that this [ __ ] dope is
taking the time to turn my podcast which
is supposed to be a break from all of
that [ __ ] which is why I just say silly
[ __ ] about it you turn this into Meet
the Press if that [ __ ] [ __ ] shoots
one up point it right at my house
because I don't want to survive it I
don't give a [ __ ] all right we have no
one to blame but ourselves we're [ __ ]
defective if human beings were cars we
would all be recalled all right we do
not handle position of power well and
this is what the [ __ ] happens all right
we're fearful [ __ ] lunatics who for
some stupid reason we're given the
ability
to [ __ ] intimidate nerds so they would
build all this [ __ ] for us and now here
we are here we are alright alright North
Korea also has the highest percentage of
slaves in the world fully it like you
care sir like you give a [ __ ]
fully 4.4 percent of its population is
enslaved that is approximately 1.1
million sir I am on an Apple [ __ ]
computer right now and I'm sure you
typed yours on an Apple computer - those
people are jumping out of the factory
they're their [ __ ] slaves all the
[ __ ] that I'm wearing was made in
sweatshops like what are we doing now
now we're going to fudge the [ __ ]
numbers so these people look like
they're out of their minds but everybody
else is [ __ ] ok this is like
countries are like community colleges
where they will figure out what their
number 1 and so they can [ __ ] put it
in their pamphlet ok let's read some
more [ __ ] depressing information this
is why I don't watch the news today that
the day and that doesn't even mention
the network of concentration camps
across the nation and the people getting
less than some less than subsistent
levels of daily calories well I mean
they're also not allowed to trade with
anybody are they you know they really
can't get this [ __ ] going right I mean
part of that is us trying to force them
into giving in to getting Forever 21's
in Starbucks there isn't that right I
mean I might be wrong sir I [ __ ]
watch sports i watch sports I listen to
music ok I block all this [ __ ] out so
I'm sure I mispronounce some words here
to put that into perspective about 388
thousand slaves were shipped to North
America from 1525 date-night 1866 it's
obviously a huge issue well how do you
how do you put that in perspective
without telling me what the population
of Korea is and also three hundred
eighty eight thousand people back in
between 1525 and 1866 was a way more
significant portion of the population
than it is today
so I don't know what you're saying there
sir but I do know that whenever we have
an issue with the country all of a
sudden we pretend to care about its
people unfortunately there isn't any
easy solution to the problem even if
China withdraws their support and the
regime regime collapses you're still
looking at a potential civil war in a
nation with nuclear weapons let's just
hold people smarter than you are I can
find a different solution to the problem
then they won't there's only one
solution got to go in there and get him
keep up the good work I love hearing you
talk about us how awesome it is to be a
parent instead of constant talk about
how hard it is as a dad of two boys
there are obviously days when I feel
like ripping out what little hair I have
left but the vast vast majority of the
time it's just awesome look at this he
was actually just informing me and I got
all [ __ ] defensive because all this
week people said that I said nuclear
instead of nuclear yes sir I realized
he's out of his [ __ ] mind
I realized that person's out of his
[ __ ] mind a guy before his dad was
out of his [ __ ] mind okay Trump is out
of his [ __ ] mind I'm out of my
[ __ ] mind okay nobody should have
weapons other than you [ __ ] fists and
whatever you can grab in the kitchen
that's ideally that's what that would be
better all right I think I don't
understand why war is legal but it is so
this is the game that we play with each
other and it is [ __ ] inevitable that
one day somebody is going to go Martin
Sheen dead zone and what are you going
to do yet he'll see people this is why I
have all four sports packages because I
don't want to know about this [ __ ] I
don't want to [ __ ] sit there and
watch the news and have them scare the
living [ __ ] out of me that now this is
going to happen you know and some flies
going to bite me and then I'm gonna have
a baby with a little head somebody else
is going to [ __ ] blow me up
yeah just I just yeah I don't want to
talk about this okay
trying to keep it light on the podcast
here let's just make let's just laugh at
me not be
it will pronounce words don't bring
actual facts into this podcast all right
girls softball team punished hey there
Billy batting glove did you hear about
the girls softball team that was removed
from the World Series because of a
picture of some of the players flicking
off the camera on social media one of
the girls on the team is the daughter of
family friend it's [ __ ] brutal yeah I
mean I don't know I don't know what I
don't understand social media I'm kind
of over it other than for business
purposes I don't just don't think it's a
good thing that should just been a funny
picture that they all took shared
amongst themselves but now you upload it
and everybody sees it and you know
somebody's going to get offended
let me guess were they the best were
they probably were the number one seed
this sounds like if one of those Bad
News Bears thinks they removed from the
World Series well well you know you know
people are they're trying to make money
they make money off that World Series is
it a national thing I don't know it's
like the Colin Kaepernick thing
everybody's [ __ ] flipping out and
immediately thinking that this guy's not
getting hired because of racism it's
like the NFL is a [ __ ] corporation
okay you know what they give a [ __ ]
about money now look if he was trying to
get a coaching job or own a team then
yeah I would say racism would be more
obvious but like what he does most of
the league is black doing okay the thing
is there's such cheap [ __ ] [ __ ] they
would rather lose a [ __ ] game they
probably have an algorithm going like
okay if we get this guy and he wins a
few more games
how many jerseys will we sell versus the
amount of people who won't buy a jersey
because we signed this guy and I swear
to God if if we'll sell a [ __ ] jersey
less by signing a guy who would actually
make us a better [ __ ] team I swear
they will decide not to sign the guy I
don't think I'm not saying that it isn't
racism involved but it
really it's [ __ ] economics and what
these [ __ ] corporations try to do is
they they don't want any [ __ ] they
want smooth [ __ ] water
that's what they want everybody [ __ ]
just tow the [ __ ] line that's what
they want and I'll tell you all these
[ __ ] groups that are trying to make
change know that [ __ ]
which is why they always complain to the
advertisers because the advertisers will
then pull sponsorship from TV shows
they'll do it from [ __ ] podcasts
everybody knows that so the NFL is a
corporation so that's what they're doing
I don't know what the [ __ ] lead these
girls are in but I'm sure they have some
sort of stupid conduct thing that
they're trying to you know trying to
uphold yeah it's [ __ ] stupid it's
also [ __ ] stupid to upload that
picture I mean how many of these dumb
stories you're going to see where people
get offended by absolutely nothing and
then something happens right
that's unfortunate it's unfortunate all
right Trent Reznor this is like a way
more serious podcast than I ever want to
do I don't know I don't know I have to
do I'm going to just start making up
[ __ ] here I try to read the news but
it's just all depressing although the
funny one was all this [ __ ] coming out
about Lady Diana now I just don't
understand how new evidence twenty years
later they're fine and they found out
that [ __ ] she was listening the
Prince Charles jerking off talking to
some other lady on a toilet did somebody
have that tape for [ __ ] 20 years
going hate to listen to this I swear to
God don't tell anybody I have this I'm
going to release it when the time is
right and then you just hear the echoing
sound of Prince Charles going oh I'm
getting pudding you ass your arse all
right Trent Reznor article a Billy Boy
Billy Boy I thought you could relate to
this Trent Reznor talks about what it's
like to meet his parents kids you meant
to say his kid's parents while having a
body of work with lyrics like I want to
[ __ ] you like an animal yeah I read that
article but never underestimate the
power of celebrity and especially I
don't know he's an older dad
so maybe they don't even know what his
[ __ ] music is but you know I wouldn't
give a [ __ ] I sang I downloaded that
[ __ ] so I [ __ ] loved his self that
[ __ ] came out like that album blew my
[ __ ] mind IV latest trend [ __ ]
resident hey sweetheart that's Trent
[ __ ] resident success I would give a
[ __ ] you know but it's got to be weird
but then this of course the people that
don't like it you know the people that
read like the 4-h club and you know at
them he wanted to [ __ ] someone like an
animal and he expressed it alright
caught girlfriend cheating after joining
the military and I legally can't leave
her what she's a girlfriend alright dear
Billy ball balls these are good this
week you guys usually you know lately
there's been a little drought you need a
[ __ ] funny this week alright
greetings from school and recently I
quit my well-paying job to join the
British Royal Marines my girlfriend of
four years was very hesitant and didn't
want me to leave but it had been a dream
of mine since I was 14 i sat her down a
week before leaving and gave her the
opportunity to separate like my
girlfriend of four years was very
hesitant and didn't want me to leave but
had been dreaming since I wasn't good i
sat down with her a week before leaving
and gave her the opportunity to separate
on good terms and maybe continue our
relationship when I had finished my
mandatory four years service but if we
stayed together but we stay if we stayed
together and she cheated she would be
dead to me I'm half Sicilian by the way
she chose to stay the fact that you
would given her the option to leave I
mean how much do you give a [ __ ] about
this woman I was in for just over four
weeks and fell during a run and a six
six months of a guy stood on my leg
breaking my tibia in two places oh [ __ ]
I was given the choice of staying in
medical custody on base and rejoined
training when I had healed or leaving
for a year I chose to leave so I could
spend more time with my girlfriend Oh
oh I thought it would be a nice surprise
to not tell her I was coming home oh
Jesus I arrived home around 9 p.m. on
Thursday oh my god to find my girl
oh Jesus choking on some guy's dick Wow
so what did you throw your [ __ ]
crutches at him naturally my instinct
was to beat the [ __ ] out of the guy but
I'm not too mobile with the pair of
crutches I forced the two out of my
house and kept my promise of you're dead
to me by changing the locks the next
morning and blocking her number and
social media accounts around two weeks
later I received a letter from a lawyer
saying that if I don't take her back she
can legally take half of all my assets
including the house my mother left me in
her will because we had been together
for more than two years what I thought
you had to be married but lo and behold
the British justice system does me
another solid I could understand if I
was away on tour from nine months and
she cheated but four weeks [ __ ] four
weeks you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
so I just take the loss and leave this
dumb [ __ ] what do I take her back and
try to forget the fact that she took the
first opportunity she had to jump on
jump another guy's bone your bones your
input would be great and maybe can put a
funny twist on this [ __ ] up
opportunity for your listeners dude you
need to get a [ __ ] lawyer you need to
get that [ __ ] out of your life and get
a [ __ ] lawyer that's what you need to
do alright that's one of the dumbest
laws I've ever heard in my life and
that's going to cause that's going to
cause people to make some really [ __ ]
up decisions if someone can screw them
that [ __ ] bad all right over here
it's a statutory not statutory rape what
is it what is it what is the [ __ ] law
when you've been illegally married that
squatter's rights what the [ __ ] is it I
don't know over here it's like you got
to be living with somebody for like
seven years depending on the state at
that point they considered it's so dumb
they
that she's entitled to half your [ __ ]
especially if she's not making any money
and you're [ __ ] paying for everything
you know is [ __ ] ridiculous
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean
I mean how many [ __ ] stories they do
out there about men beating women and
how awful men are to [ __ ] women right
which obviously they got to shine a
light on that but look at this she's
going to just [ __ ] [ __ ]
who suck this other guy's dick doesn't
could care less about taking half of the
house that your mother left you oh my
god what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude I would get a lawyer I would get oh
my god would get a [ __ ] lawyer what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude like I I
don't I can't even this is like making
me angry that someone could do that to
somebody what kind of a piece of [ __ ]
the kind of person that [ __ ] blows
somebody for weeks ever but even then
there's plenty of women that would do
that there's plenty of [ __ ] women
that would do that anyone take your
[ __ ] house they were raised right
they get caught sucking a dick the guy
you're not fair enough and they leave
Jesus cry we get a lawyer sir I would
get a lawyer and I would [ __ ] fight
this thing
find some [ __ ] thing - oh my god the
advice that I want to give you I can't
say over this because I'll be liable
okay and it's like all right let me tell
let me tell a [ __ ] little story here
um now I can't I can't do it I can't
tell the story because I'll get in
[ __ ] trouble I won't sir you know
what I would get a lawyer and handle it
legally don't do anything [ __ ] crazy
all right Jesus Christ what I can't do
I'll tell you right there man you you
met one for the ages
that's a first-ballot Hall of Fame [ __ ]
if I ever [ __ ] heard of one good lord
I could see if she caught you and then
out of vindictiveness then did that that
you know they'd be like well you know
what the [ __ ] but she's going to do that
and then take half your [ __ ] house
you know what kills me when she tells
the story she I'm not saying she'll play
them she won't be in the run I mean
that's a [ __ ] psychopath thank God
you didn't breed with her man jesus
[ __ ] christ
Jesus Christ well you know what thank
you for your service sir you know what
these [ __ ] can take everything you got
there's nothing you can [ __ ] do about
that's how the laws are set up and I got
to be honest with you dude you know
worst case scenario if she takes your
path your house and have to [ __ ] even
still considering what the [ __ ] they can
do to you you actually got off easy
easier than a lot of guys did but Jesus
Christ can I apologize for this podcast
I don't want to get involved in world
politics I don't want to talk about
North Korea I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about you know what I mean
and for the 18 people that are going to
take any of this [ __ ] [ __ ] seriously
I don't give a [ __ ] let's just keep it
to correcting my [ __ ] spelling shall
we
I'm going to end this [ __ ] podcast on
an upbeat note it's joe de Rosas
birthday today at goddamnit he's coming
home from [ __ ] Hampstead and I've got
a fake birthday Joey roses happy
birthday Joey roses over I came I can't
sing the song if you ever heard this
[ __ ] songs we sing to each other I
mean just I'm trying to think of a group
that would be offended by it well I know
the one group in particular I literally
can't even sing in the [ __ ] this is just
whole thing just went off the [ __ ]
rails this whole podcast went off the
rails because that was one that was such
a [ __ ] do you know what I did you
know because I've been stuck in the
writers room and I haven't been going
out doing stand-up and seeing people and
having stories to tell you what I do
before I get on the podcast now as I
just click on Google News and it's just
the most horrific [ __ ] you know that
[ __ ] ride that broke in Ohio [ __ ]
18-year old kid died kid was born in
1999 died going to a [ __ ] amusement
park somebody blew up a mosque tried to
and [ __ ] in Minneapolis I don't
understand how people sit there and they
watch CNN and Fox and all that [ __ ] just
like what does it do for you to stay
informed I have a [ __ ] I don't know
what I'd be [ __ ] I don't want to say
I want to sit the [ __ ] that would be
doing it's not fun anymore I get it you
know what I got to do I'm gonna watch I
promise you guys I'm just going to watch
sports between now and Thursday and I'm
going to do something I'm going to go to
a mall or something I'll just make fun
of fat people when I get back I
apologize for the heaviness of this
podcast alright go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday over there